now to an exclusive interview with
Mexican president Enrique Pena Nieto he
sat down a bloomberg editor-in-chief
john nichols wait who asked him if he
plans to reappoint mexico central bank
head Agustin Carstens attend a simple
note oddly I think he has done an
excellent job and I have to say that he
has acted very professionally and he has
been demonstrated as a governor of the
Central Bank of Mexico he also proved
his diligence in other financial areas
for example the International Monetary
Fund president Pena Nieto went on to say
he'll announce his final decision in
December and you can hear more of our
exclusive interview with him tomorrow
right here on Bloomberg Television
joining me now is Bloomberg anchor Mark
Crumpton with more on this the midterm
elections mark just held over the
weekend what's the takeaway interesting
because there was some sense that maybe
it might have been at least some of the
people of Mexico saying that they are
not pleased with the policies of mr.
Pena Nieto but that doesn't seem to be
the case because he may hold on to his
majority his PRI PRI party they've been
an entrenched power in Mexico for
decades but it was interesting about mr.
Carson's because didn't seem that
president Pena Nieto gave him a ringing
endorsement did it you know he's going
to have to say what did he say we'll
wait and see until december i looked up
some stuff about mr. carstens while he's
been the head of the central bank in
Mexico it's cut rates to a record low
three percent to boost an economy that's
repeatedly been below forecasts that's
when Mexico's problem for a while now
inflation is slowed to the lowest level
since nineteen sixty eight back in May
it was at 2.8 eight percent mr. Carson
said that if he was asked for a second
term he'd accept but he hasn't been
asked yet it's not the kind of thing you
can see with a US government official
right I mean a president normally if
asked if he's going to keep one of his
secretary one of his cabinet members
will say we stand fully behind him and
is that not the case in New York Jay
you're a political historian but you
know what's interesting because it's
almost like that is not the ringing
endorsement because if the president
says we stand behind you one hundred
percent that usually means you're one
foot out the door alright but we're
gonna
have to wait and see but again that
interview by mr. Michaels wait with a
president Pena Nieto can see that on
bloomberg.com that's fascinating